oh now hi guys my name is great
salvation unknown I know your life is
different now I'm here with dr. Paul
you guys should know because if you know
me you know I'm obsessed with this human
being because he's just a bundle of
talent that just oozes constantly a good
enough reason see I feel very wrong
because we just have a video for todrick
channel and which be reveal her deepest
darkest Ygritte debit I'll be either one
of us told other humans in years
forever I've done please go over this
channel and check out that video because
we're very sweaty but now we're having
happy fun times here is a Broadway
veteran for this three rubbish I found
you and the most reasonable arm of kinky
boots I got to see in New York and you
were so outstanding I cried my eyes out
so fantastic your makeup and your entire
look was incredible thank you
and I know that you're such a huge fan
of RuPaul's Drag Race so these two
things goodbye meant but todrick might
be the perfect version to do drag makeup
on my face
except for club back I've never done
makeup in my entire life
but I think that I could be good at it I
know Manning anyway star Patrick star
but on todrick star for today
no I tech to do this and you were like
I've never done makeup corn I was like
perfect
I assume that you dabble she's not that
was Appalachian beginning here canvas
you can do whatever you want I want you
to look good I don't want it to be look
like a trash box that is my friend also
like first of all not only drag but it's
drag on a drug for budget right alright
setting us up for failure a little bit
how long it take you to do Lola's make
let's do Lola make up about an hour all
right and I want to have to hit for my
look for Milo video thank but value
looks just like three or four hours what
is this that is foundation so okay and
so I just think that this understandable
if you knock
he's very you know I don't know where
did you go to start okay I know that
there's like a lot of contouring that
happens yes and I see people do this all
the time literally what the same as when
we started what is Paterno I didn't
contro perfection whatever one you want
you're an ardent do that good yeah I
know don't over here all at Wow
look like you're for sure enough bad
production of cat cat looks terrible
can't get food maybe feels
how tall are the group five and half
that I can either lost five men and cute
I'm there like adult it walks on tight
like that's how I am Ocelot malaise just
fall down today any other glasses on
this never looks believable that it's
alright something like to clear it I'm
very intently listening you're
definitely using black liquid liner one
but I got it all wrong on that or is it
great if you need to book me like
getting some videos after this video I'm
gonna be like Oh take me seriously okay
you guys be still about compression
absolutely really serious makeup you
look Rick thank you or you can make up
our know how does equal to this my hand
is like wait a minute you're so scary
about poking me but don't worry beauty
and say never political is it but a lot
of really thank you Oh bags under my
eyes
yeah I'm very tired I think you'd be
great at that
but I like a boy back together I just
missed scream I want you to put cream
together didn't he did he put together
Danny Caine that's why I remember yeah
you get the dream
oh isn't dream I don't know did I make
Gayatri you drab that this is close my
head vacant put that glitter wherever
you want a ham don't you get the see no
no no no you look lush you're ready for
Broadway
hey can you think no I can scream what's
your carry out a thought well when I'm
trying to impress someone like it is
right that I would think I'll be by head
with the chain and look them straight in
the like a Tuesday I'll say I love rock
yo this is the most awkward thing would
be boiling all right I like the thank
you okay
they're doing they're honest but uh yeah
wide awake but awake no I just want to
give you a little bit of personality you
know hey because everyone can get mad
all that everybody can't be great joking
oh boy and I wanna get my signature
saying I think you're ready there I
think you're ready to the stage oh my
god Wow an ironic straw that I brought
that a lot of personality Nestle this
one I'm sure yet that she the look alert
my nose has never look skinnier thank
you oh my god so five guys to meet the
recommendations for drag queen names
down in the comments below because I
feel ready you're ready to live my best
life thank you so much todrick
you look like we party cycle over to
capture channel because we weren't real
really dark sexual secrets and make sure
you guys check out a few jokes of not
too deep incisors and it gets on it and
no fun the whole time like everywhere I
look you guys whenever I don't know see
them at the gay club tonight
right now right